Today
is a day for truth.
The world needs to know what happened.
And to know what he stands for.
That kind of power is very dangerous.
Let the record show that this committee holds him responsible.
That how it starts,
the fever,
the rage
that turns good man
cruel.
This bat vigilante
is like a one-man reign of terror.
You don't get to decide what the right thing is.
Nobody cares about Clark Kent taking on the batman.
This means something.
It's all some people have.
It's all that gives them hope.
People hate what they don't understand.
Be their hero, Clark,
be their angel, be their monument.
Be anything they need you to be...
...or be none of it.
You don't owe this world a thing,
you never did.
Do you know the oldest lie in America, Senator?
Devils don't come from hell beneath us,
they come from the sky.
Twenty year in Gotham,
how many good guys are left?
How many stayed that way?
He has the power to wipe out the entire human race.
I only have to destroy him.
You're gonna cause a war.
He is not our enemy.
Black and blue.
God versus man.
The day versus night.
The red capes are coming.
Hey youtubers, it's Charlie.
So, this is gonna be my breakdown of the Batman versus Superman footage.
I know the Suicide Squad trailer leaked too.
This is like the Batman versus Superman trailer they showed in Hall H.
They also show that Suicide Squad footage
but they've been pulling it down so I just,
I can't post any of the Suicide Squad stuff
so I'll just talk about it after Batman versus Superman.
But just a couple things right of the top.
Zack Snyder clarified just
a couple big things about the film.
There is some big changes to comic book canon.
He said the most agreegeous thing that he changed
is that now Metropolis exists right next to Gotham City.
As in like, they're separated by a bay.
And in the wake of Superman's battle with the other kryptonians, with Zod,
it's become this, you know,
very much prosperous versus decrepit city.
Like, in the way of the attack
Gotham has fallen on hard times
like we see in the trailer,
like the Wayne financial building coming down.
That's part of the thing that
shakes Batman back into action.
He's existed in this universe for a while,
and I know it seems like he's becoming the batman for the first time,
but he's actually been retired when the movie picks up.
So it's like "Oh shit! Kryptonians here!
We need to kill 'em."
Like he says in the trailer.
He can kill the entire human race.
We have to get rid of them.
So that shakes him back into action,
so he goes back into training.
But as much as the movie has like shots,
like visual things that are totally inspired
by Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns.
The movie story,
like the story itself has nothing to do with it.
If you've seen the panel video that I posted, I mean,
he says it out right, he just says that
the story is something that we made up
in a room by ourselves,
it has nothing to do with the comics.
But what I think is really cool is the way they are pitting Superman and Batman against each other.
Is not just two superheroes, you know,
with two different ideologies, going at each other.
They're also using their alter egos to do it.
Batman is using his wealth as Bruce Wayne,
to create batman tech to take on Superman.
And Superman is using his position
as a reporter at The Daily Planet
to take on this batman vigilante.
You know, air quotes.
I like the way that they put that in the trailer.
"Batman vigilante"
You have to remember that Clark Kent
has no idea who the Batman is.
But, Batman is probably gonna figure out
who Clark Kent is, really fast.
Standing in between them
is Lex Luthor with a giant kryptonite rock
and Zod's body.
The way they cut the trailer it seem kinda vague.
LIke we don't know if it's the military, the US military,
that has Zod's body or Lex Corp.
But I think that it's Lex Corp.
Even though in the movie Lex Corp is a tech company,
is not like Lex Corp in the comics.
To be fair though,
when you're like a billion dollar company,
you have your hands in a lot of different pies.
So you can rationalize him synthesizing kryptonite,
you know, anyway you want.
I mean, he has a billion dollars,
he does whatever he feels like doing.
Jesse Eisenberg is wearing a wig in this trailer.
He is bald.
But we might not see actually go bald till the end of the movie. That might be something that they save.
For the most part, what looks like it's happening in this movie, the big conflict, is going to be superhero registration.
You know, people so powerful that they can destroy the human race.
They need to be controlled.
So that's probably how we find out about all the other metahumans in the world.
Like we find about Aquaman,
all the other big superheroes that are going to become part of Justice League.
Superman causing all this damage
and making everyone shit their pants
is gonna put all these other supers on the radar.
So as much as he has his own, like cult-like following, the people that worship him as a god.
Like he even has this security force, that's taking down the Batman, with superman symbols on their arms.
He is going to be the biggest antagonist of the film,
for probably, at least, the first half.
What I'm expecting, you know, based on the way that they cut this trailer, like, some of the things we saw
is that Lex Luthor will eventually become a threat so big
that Batman and Superman will have to join forces.
Presumably in Justice League, because I think,
most of this movie is gonna focus on this
Batman-Superman story.
I know there been a lot of rumors
about Doomsday and other big villans.
I'm not expecting too much of that.
It seems, you know, mostly
what's gonna be happening in this film
is that kryptonite will become a thing,
and that people will start picking sides, you know,
either your with Superman
or your with people like Lex Luthor.
Obviously, anybody that's read a comic in the last
twenty years knows that Batman is gonna switch back but
I'm really interested to see Lex Luthor
try to win Batman over.
Like if he tries to lure Bruce Wayne in.
Obviously, he probably doesn't know that he's Batman.
But what about Gal Gadot though,
it looks like she fights Superman a little bit.
It's kinda hard to tell [by] the way they cut the trailer.
Sometimes
the way they cut things can be deceptive,
but, it does look like they throw down a little bit.
Because she'd be one of the few people
that could take him on.
In the context of this universe,
she's been around for a long time, so
I think she's gonna be an example
of a well adjusted superhero.
But let me know though,
what's your favorite part from the trailer?
Aside from seeing Wonder Woman
finally kick some ass.
Moving unto Suicide Squad stuff though,
so, you know, biggest thing
from the Suicide Squad footage
is actually seeing Jared Leto's joker.
I mean, it looks dark, gritty and awsome.
You know, once we get a nice high quality version,
you know, which hopefully they'll drop pretty soon.
But for the most part, like during the panel video,
like I posted the Suicide Squad panel,
the director David Ayer said
they're being faithful to the comics,
he's talking 'bout the classic Suicide Squad,
like the eighties Suicide Squad.
But they have a giant cast though,
like almost every single mayor Suicide Squad character that ever was.
Right now, just because we don't have a lot of context,
I'm cautiously optimistic,
but I do, I think it'll be a lot of fun.
So, what's gonna happen is
the DC, like, super Flarrow-Legends panel
like, you know, all the DC tv shows
is happening tonight
I'm gonna be backstage,
so I'll be live tweeting no matter what.
But, I don't know if I'll be able to tape it or not.
They said I'm not allowed to record the screen,
so we'll see.
I'll do whatever I can to get footage,
like, they're doing a Q&A panel
and they're showing off a bunch of footage
So most of my videos for that stuff
like the Vixen trailer that just dropped,
that [I]'ll all post tomorrow.
Be sure to suscribe to get everything.
Seriously, the Vixen trailer is actually pretty exciting.
I'll talk about the premiere and all that stuff,
that's happening in August, so I'll talk about that tomorrow.
But, while you guys wait for that to drop,
you can click here for the Batman v Superman panel,
in case you haven't seen it.
And you can click on this second link down here
for all [of] my other Comic Con videos.
Just pretend like my hand is, like,
pointing up and down on the screen here.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody.
Lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.